one of the central tasks of this course
has been to unpack the ways in which
work in today's economy has changed over
time often when we talk about this topic
one of the first things that comes to
mind is a role of technology and
transforming work over the past few
years we have seen an explosion in
what's known as the undemanding onna me
it's visible everywhere we as consumers
are able to have our food delivered grab
a ride home or even have someone run
their errands all purchased and arranged
in a matter of minutes from our
smartphones our colleague John McCarthy
talks in more detail about these new
ways of organizing work in a different
video lecture in this course what we're
going to talk about now is how these
employment arrangements are connected to
two issues one how we think about
workers rights in the undemanding ohne
me and to how technology can promote new
forms of worker advocacy in settings
where gigs not full-time jobs for one
employer are becoming the employment
norm many consumers and workers alike
find the flexibility and efficiency of
the unde Amanda kana me to be beneficial
work hours are flexible for instance and
the efficiency of services saves people
time as has been pointed out however
many workers undertaking the actual jobs
of these companies are employed as
independent contractors meaning that
they are not direct employees of the
company that is bringing us the good or
the service a babysitter who gets his
work through the website care.com for
instance is considered to be
self-employed this means that the
benefits and protections that we
associate with full-time stable jobs
such as access to pay leave or
unemployment insurance are not available
to on-demand workers likewise standards
that promote good quality jobs are often
absent from these arrangements as we
seen through the recent protest by uber
drivers over wages in terms of work in
various cities so the traditional system
of benefits and protections based on
full-time jobs and employee
status no longer makes sense in these
settings innovative disruptive
technologies that change the way
business is done and work is performed
require simultaneous innovative changes
and how workers are able to access
rights on the job what we've talked
about in this course is updating the
social contract at work one approach to
such change comes with support from a
broad coalition of technology firms
labor organizations academics and
foundations the idea is pretty simple
that benefits and protections should
accrue with the work being performed no
matter the employer in other words the
number of sick days for instance a gig
worker can accrue should depend on the
number of hours she works whether
providing rides or delivering groceries
although firms would contribute to these
benefits and protections they would
essentially remain with the worker
allowing for Economic Security even when
working for multiple employers they can
be structured in a way that promotes
good jobs that pay living wages and by
making these portable benefits universal
they can also extend to workers beyond
the on-demand economy helping ease the
now commonplace transitions that many of
us experience moving from one employer
to the next the idea of portable
benefits mimics these new undemanding
insec Eric tur eyes growing portions of
the economy likewise advocates are also
finding new ways to use technology to
promote workers rights on the job in
some cases this is directly relevant to
on-demand workers themselves relatively
new websites such as co-worker org and
dynamo service online hubs where workers
can start petitions for change rate
their experience with certain employers
and connect with others in their
industry track opticon is a similar
application that allows crowd workers on
amazon's mechanical turk to rate
employers these applications complement
organizing efforts and other settings as
well in our last video we talked about
our Walmart an organization of
non-unionized wal-mart workers
advocating for better working conditions
using an online campaign through
co-worker org our Walmart was recently
able to gather widespread support for
their demands regarding more stable
hours in response Walmart changed the
way they scheduled shifts with support
from an innovative organization called
the workers lab which promotes new forms
of worker organizing our walmer is also
developing an app that allows workers to
connect with one another while receiving
peer generated advice and training
relevant to their jobs other
organizations are developing
applications that not only serve to
connect workers and mobilize around
specific demands but also to inform and
educate workers about their rights on
the job the domestic worker app for
example was created in response to the
passage of a domestic worker Bill of
Rights in New York State caregivers
nannies and cleaners can call in or text
to access both recorded and live
informational episodes and messages
about their rights under the state's new
legislation a different approach is
taken by the restaurant Opportunity
Center the organization of restaurant
workers we discussed in our last video
the center's top server app is a game
that teaches its users about the skills
needed to advance in restaurants
imparting training knowledge and even
the lingo used in restaurant work to
servers looking for ways to advance in
the industry to be clear these new forms
of advocacy are not a replacement for
direct work or organizing and other
advocacy work but as these organizations
show the types of technologies that are
transforming the way we work can also be
used to strengthen our efforts to create
good jobs and as the on-demand economy
continues to be fueled by growing
consumer demand we will continue to be
presented with opportunities for
potential innovation in reestablishing
the social contract at work not just for
on-demand workers but for all workers
throughout the economy